und zugeschaltet aus stuttgart ist uns
jetzt winfried hermann minister für
verkehr und infrastruktur in baden
württemberg also größe sie in die
landeshauptstadt von baden-württemberg
nach stuttgart hermann
guten morgen herr herrmann wir müssen
beginnen sozusagen bei dem was auf
ampelkoalition er jetzt zu kommt nämlich
politisches handeln aber wir hatten
gerade im beitrag diesen gesetzentwurf
der jetzt vorliegt seit gestern und am
donnerstag dann in erster lesung im
bundestag verhandelt wird sie sind
selber lange zeit mitglied des deutschen
bundestages gewesen es gibt jetzt ganz
viel kritik gleich schon an ihnen das
ist sowas wie die landung in der
realität kritik von städtetag kritik von
den sozialverbänden waren sie jetzt in
die ampel koalitionäre zu mutlos gleich
schon am anfang
nein das nicht aber es ist
offensichtlich so dass man eben noch
zusammenfinden muss auf der ebene der
konkreten maßnahmen dass es leichter ist
sich auf allgemeine ziele zu
verständigen aber glaubwürdig wird
politik aus dann wenn die maßnahmen
belegen dass man die ziele erreichen
kann das gilt ganz besonders für den
klimaschutz und den bereich
verkehrswende und das war halt meine
warnung darauf hinzuweisen man muss ja
zusammenkommen um konkrete maßnahmen
finden und man kann nicht sozusagen
jeden vorschlag ablehnen aber keinen
anderen alternativen vorschlag machen
das ist die aufgabe die jetzt die
verhandler in der schlussrunde haben und
da muss man zusammenkommen da müssen
auch welches sich bewegen
hermann sie sind ja nicht teil der
arbeitsgruppen aber dennoch kann man
natürlich in der perspektive und wir
dürfen davon ausgehen dass sich die
entsprechenden papiere kennen auch
kommentierungen vornehmen ganz klar sie
hatten in einem interview gestern mehr
oder weniger wörtlich formuliert wenn
wir in den nächsten tagen also beim
klimaschutz nicht weiterkommen dann
müssen wir auch neuwahlen in erwägung
ziehen das böse f wort hat viele in
berlin verschreckt
das ist wahr aber ich habe ja nur auf
eine selbstverständlichkeit hingewiesen
dass sozusagen die koalition eine
überzahl so verhandlung müssen
überzeugendes angebot machen die
jeweiligen parteibasis und übrigens auch
an die bevölkerung
ich kann ja gar nicht mit neuwahlen
drohen das habe ich nicht gesagt sondern
wir haben nur gesagt dann droht das denn
man muss eben nicht nur sagen wir wollen
zusammen regieren sondern muss auch
sagen wie wollen wir zusammen regierung
und wie wollen wir die hoch gesteckten
ziele erreichen und das ist sozusagen
die große herausforderung an die
verhandler und es können davon ausgehen
dass ich da einiges weiß und das war
auch der grund weshalb ich mich deutlich
geäußert habe jetzt muss man wirklich
konkret werden das betone ich konkret
wenn es hilft nicht nur floskeln zu
haben sondern maßnahmen die zeigen man
kann die klimaschutzziele erreichen und
da ist insbesondere die fdp gefragt also
rhetorik ist durchaus dass ein und wir
kommen auch tatsächlich auf die
inhaltliche spielfläche gleich noch aber
dass die spd sagt der aktuelle noch
parteivorsitzende walter borjans ist
eine einzelmeinung von herrn herrmann da
aus dem süden das können sie sich ja
noch locker hinnehmen wenn ihr eigener
bundesgeschäftsführer herr kellner dann
sagt das ist eine meinung zu und zeit
das recht sie doch an oder
90 mich nicht an weil ich habe mit
vielen gesprochen und es war der
allgemeine tenor und es gab da schon
auch einen deutlichen frust ich will das
ja auch nicht kaputtreden von außen
sondern ich will nur sagen hier ist
sozusagen noch arbeit angesagt und wie
ich höre hat sich ja auch schon letzten
tagen einiges bewegt das ist ja auch das
gute offensichtlich kann man ja auch mal
einen anstoß geben die finde es ist gut
dass in ruhe verhandelt wird aber es
kann ja kein allgemeines schweigen geben
also ich meine die verhandeln sind ja
nicht die einzelnen die politik machen
hermann also können wir noch mal auf
diese inhaltliche spielfläche sehr als
minister für verkehr und infrastruktur
in baden württemberg haben natürlich
einen speziellen ein blick insbesondere
auf diesen mobilitäts und
verkehrsbereich da hatten sie jetzt
sagen wir mal auch eine relativ scharfe
kritik an der fdp geäußert was genau
stört sie hatten glaube ich zwei punkte
in mitten im interview erwähnt nämlich
die frage der pendlerpauschale und die
frage des dienstwagen privilegs was
genau stellen sie sich vor
also man muss vielleicht noch zu sagen
dass in den letzten 30 jahren in allen
bereichen fortschritte beim klimaschutz
erzielt wurden im verkehrsbereich nicht
keine reduktion das hat auch viel damit
zu tun dass eine reihe von fiskalischen
regelungen haben die kontraproduktiv
sind etwa das dienstwagenprivileg
dann die
besondere besteuerung von diesel dann
bei der pendlerpauschale gibt es um
soziale elemente es gibt einfach
randbedingungen die verhindern dass es
eine verkehrswende gibt und das muss man
ändern und es gibt auch regeln zum
beispiel tempo beschränken oder nicht
beschränkung die ihren einfluss haben
auf klimaschutzmaßnahmen oder auf den
klimaschutzeffekt und es war halt die
kritik dass man nicht alles ablehnen
kann und dann meinen dass man irgendwas
erreicht ist es völlig klar es muss sich
was ändern es mit sie verhaltensweisen
ändern es müssen regeln geändert werden
es müssen auch störche subventions
tatbestände abgebaut werden wenn man das
nicht tut werden im verkehrssektor
keinen erfolg haben und wir brauchen den
erfolg im verkehrssektor denn es ist
inzwischen in baden württemberg der
größte emittent in sachen klima
schädliche gase auf bundesebene ist es
nicht ganz so schlimm aber es ist ein
relevanter bereich und es gibt keinen
klimaschutz oder verkehrswende und das
muss man sehr klar sagen auch denen die
da zögerlicher sind das sagt jemand der
minister es an einem durchaus noch
automobilstandort in deutschland mit
daimler und porsche hermann dann noch
mal ganz konkret sie fordern die
abschaffung der pendlerpauschale und die
abschaffung des dienstwagen privilegs
sagen sie es doch bitte noch mal an
einem hauptsatz
also erstens muss sagen gerade im
autoland weiß ich dass die großen
automobilunternehmen sagen wir können
die transformation wir können schneller
zu klimafreundlichen fahrzeugen und zur
klimafreundlichen verkehrsmitteln kommen
da ist die wirtschaft inzwischen schon
weiter als manche in der politik und was
die pendlerpauschale anlagen habe ich
nicht gesagt die abschaffung sondern sie
muss sozialverträglich umgestaltet
werden und sie muss ökologisch
abgeschossen logischen gründen
abgeschmolzen werden beim dienstwagen
privileg bin ich zu meinen wir können
nicht weiter dienstwagen die
klimaschädlich sind auch noch
privilegieren und das sind so zwei
beispiele die einfach zeigen man muss an
dem bisherigen system was ändern im
sinne von mehr klimaschutz und mehr
soziale gerechtigkeit
wer beim klimaschutz viel verspricht
muss am ende auch liefern das war die
meinung des grünen verkehrs und
infrastrukturminister aus baden
württemberg winfried hermann vielen dank
für das phoenix tagesgespräch danken